That’s it!!
I’m so tired of this.
I’ve had it up to here.
There’s this awful myth about airplanes:
An airplane is able to fly because of Bernoulli’s Principle.
It’s wrong and we’re going to fix it!
OK crazies, let’s start by debunking the
wrong explanation.
What is Bernoulli’s Principle?
It’s basically conservation of energy for
fluids, you know, like air or water.
Let’s break it down!
Bernoulli’s Principle actually tells us
a lot about moving fluids
as long as they’re not doing anything too
crazy.
This is the energy the molecules have to bump
into things, including each other.
This is the gravitational energy of the fluid
relative to the Earth.
and this is the energy the fluid has because
it’s moving.
The total of the three can’t ever change,
So, if one gets bigger, another one has to
get smaller.
It accurately predicts a higher pressure at
the bottom of the ocean.
and a lower pressure at the top of Mount Everest.
What does this have to do with planes?
That’s where the moving part comes in.
If you get fluids like air to move, they’re
going to have less pressure,
which lets me do this,
and this,
and even this.
The airplane myth states something like this:
The shape of the wing forces the air to move
faster over the top of the wing than the bottom.
The pressure difference then lifts the plane.
False!
The shape of the wing is called an “airfoil”
and yes, there are wings shaped like that.
However!
That whole idea of air-speed over and under
a wing hinges on a huge assumption.
That all the air molecules get to the back
of the wing at the same time,
which isn’t necessarily true.
Yes, sometimes Bernoulli’s Principle can
give a plane wing extra lift,
but it’s nowhere near enough to lift a plane
on its own.
There are also other types of wings shaped
like this,
or like this,
or even this!
Some plane wings don’t use Bernoulli’s
Principle at all and the plane still flies.
Other planes can fly upside down!
On top of that,
air isn’t very well-behaved around wings,
which is why they sometimes put those little
winglets on the end.
Air turbulence really messes up Bernoulli’s
Principle.
Bottom line, Bernoulli’s Principle is about energy
and plane flight isn’t.
So then how do planes fly, smarty-pants?
Conservation of Momentum.
First of all, plane wings are not level with
the cabin.
Say you’ve got a plane at cruising altitude,
flying level to the ground.
The wings are tilted slightly upward in the
front.
It’s called the “Angle of Attack.”
HIYA!
As a result, the bottom of the wing is exposed
to the incoming air.
Those air molecules smash into the wing and
bounce off.
That’s where conservation of momentum comes
in.
If you want to know how one thing is going
to affect another,
you need to know two things about it:
How massive it is and how fast it’s going.
The bigger either one is, the more it can
do.
“Momentum” is just the combination of
those two factors.
Basically, it measures how much oomph something
has.
Back to the wing!
Air molecules have a really low mass.
So low, that even if you have a lot of them,
it’s still not going to be anywhere near
the mass of the plane.
The only way to get enough momentum into those
little collisions
is to make the air molecules move really fast.
Fast! Fast!
The loss of momentum for the air molecules
is in this direction.
So, by conservation of momentum, the gain
for the wings is in this direction.
Any change in momentum results in a force
in that direction,
which, for planes, we usually split into two
parts:
An unavoidable drag resisting the forward
motion of the plane
and a lift toward the sky.
As long as the angle of attack
HIYA!!
is relatively small, the drag should also
be small
and the lift should be big enough to hold
the pane off the ground.
You’re welcome!
Thanks for liking this video and subscribing
to the channel.
Please share this video with as many people
as possible.
Together, we can kill this myth once and for all!
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.
In the last video, we discovered why humans
have such trouble with time.
Comment response time!
Portantvas was a little disappointed I didn’t
mention twice-baked bread.
Otherwise known as biscuits.
No really, the word “biscuit” came from
the Latin “bis coctus,”
which literally means “twice-baked.”
But to respond, I did originally have it written
into the video.
I just couldn’t find a decent and free picture of one,
so I removed it at the last minute.
Apurba Bisvas was glad to see the channel
branching out from physics topics.
Right, this the Science Asylum, not the Physics
Asylum.
I always want to do non-physics videos and I do occasionally.
The thing is though, I am a physicist,
so physics videos require a lot less research.
I’ve got most of it up here.
But, when I have the time, I try to venture
out of my comfort zone
and do something a little different.
So expect occasional non-physics videos in
the future.
Amit Patel suggested I should pay to have
some of my videos featured on YouTube.
Well, I don’t think you can pay to be on
any trending lists.
I’m pretty sure that’s just an algorithm
thing.
I know you can pay to have your videos be
pre-roll-ads on other videos.
and, while I have tried that a couple times,
the amount of money you have to spend
to make that worth it is outrageous.
It’s just not a viable option for channel with a budget this small.
David Ndiulor, Ndiulor, Ndiulor...
I'm so sorry.
He thinks Wikipedia gets its facts from me.
That’s not entirely untrue.
I have edited on Wikipedia before.
Mostly pages on special and general relativity.
It’s what I know the best.
Ramiro Rivera commented about my Dora reference.
Thanks, I worked really hard making Swiper
Clone. I'm glad somebody noticed him.
He’s after the credits in case anyone missed
him.
And to everyone who suggested ideas for a
10k sub celebration or 100th video,
I am considering them.
Really great ideas!
Anyway, thanks for watching!